القمه الاقليميه تاتي على خلفيه الذكرى
السنويه للحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا والتي
واجهت ضربه للاقتصاد في جميع انحاء العالم
وفي وقت تتطلع فيه دول اسيا الوسطى لتخفيف
اعتمادها على موسكو في التجاره والامن
وغير ذلك ومع استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا
اعتمد قاده دول اسيا الوسطى موقفا متوازنا
من النزاع مع البقاء على حذر كبير بسبب
الاتفاقيات الرسميه مع موسكو والوزن
الاقتصادي والامني لروسيا الجمهوريه
السوفيتي السابقه الخمس كانت امتنعت او لم
تشارك في التصويت الذي جرى الخميس الماضي
في الجمعيه العموميه للامم المتحده على
مشروع قانون يطلب من القوات الروسيه
مغادره اوكرانيا رغم الحديث عن الابتعاد
عن روسيا الا ان دول اسيا الوسطى لم تنفصل
تماما عن موسكو مع استمرار بعض الدول في
السماح بنقل البضائع الخاضعه للعقوبات الى
روسيا حتى وان انتقدت علنا السياسات
الروسيه
على الطرف الاخر وعدد كازاخستان بزياده
صادرات النفط الى اوروبا عبر الطرق التي
لا تمر عبر روسيا خاصه وان الاخيره اغلقت
مرتين في الاشهر القليله الماضيه خط
انابيب بحر قزوين الذي ينقل ما يقرب من
ثمانين في المئه من صادرات كازاخستان
النفطيه عبر روسيا الى البحر الاسود ومع
توقع تراجع نفوذ موسكو بدا الدول الاخرى
تحاول ايجاد مكان لها في المنطقه الغنيه
بمصادر الطاقه والموارد المعدنيه الهائله
الصين من هذه الدول ونذكر ان الزياره
الخارجيه الاولى للرئيس للخارج منذ بدء
جائحه كوفيد كانت الى كازاخستان
ايضا تحظى تركيا بتقارب اكبر مع دول
المنطقه الناطقه جميعها بالتركيه ما عدا
تاجيكستان وعلى الاراضي التركيه التقوا
رؤساء من دول المنطقه بالرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان خلال الاشهر الماضيه لعقد صفقات
مع انقره لشراء اسلحه وطائرات بيرقدار
المسيره كما وقعت كازاخستان صفقه لانتاج
طائرات عسكريه تركيه دون طيار في
كازاخستان
[موسيقى]